we need to go farther on the right than
we have gone in the past because
for the past let's just call it 20 years
even though it's been a little longer
than that
on the right we have pushed back just
hard enough to lose
to lose to lose on every major issue
except occasionally tax cuts which then
the taxes go right back up when the
democrats win so we just lose
lose but we lose kind of slowly we lose
sometimes in a gradual way though
increasingly it's accelerating
so that means you got to push back a
little bit harder which brings me to
two guys that i really really admire uh
who
i just think we disagree on this issue a
professor robbie george legendary
conservative
professor at princeton i actually hosted
an event
or moderated an event at the rogers
scrutin legacy foundation with professor
george
a few weeks ago he was tweeting out
about the issue of critical race theory
and he gave what i think has been the
kind of
conservative consensus opinion of the
last 20 or so years
where he said i know i'm old-fashioned
but i can't help thinking that what
makes sense in academic institutions is
not to ban critical race theory
or any other viewer approach but also
not to give it a monopoly or privileged
position over other views and approaches
what's wrong with that pause there for a
second because i think there is
something quite wrong with that but
we'll pause that uh christopher ruffa
who's doing
superb work in city journal exposing
critical race theory
he responds respectfully professor
nobody is suggesting a ban on critical
race theory in academic work or the
classroom
we're suggesting a ban on mandatory
workplace trainings
that force people to accept the values
of race essentialism collective guilt
and neo-segregation so
i i will respond here first to chris
ruffo
i am suggesting a ban on critical race
theory i am not merely suggesting
that we ban the mandates in workplaces
or anything like that
i am suggesting in in public schools and
public colleges
and outright ban on this stuff in the
classroom and in private colleges and
universities
i'm encouraging the faculty and the
students
and the parents and the trustees and the
people who
fund the endowment i am suggesting that
these people
force this trash out of the classroom
not to open up the classroom to other
ideas and we're all inclusive and no i'm
saying
exclude that trash and
the view that i'm espousing i think is
the old-fashioned view
that's the old-fashioned view that has
reigned until very very recently
that's the old-fashioned view that
william f buckley jr articulated in god
and man at yale
subtitled the superstitions of academic
freedom
which is widely credited with beginning
the post-war conservative movement
i know it's very fashionable on the
right right now
to embrace academic freedom and to say
that
in the classroom all views should be
heard at all times that is not a
conservative view
that is a liberal view that the left
has tricked us into accepting and
specifically did so in the 1960s and
1970s
through the extraordinarily dishonest
berkeley free speech movement
inappropriately named because look where
that free speech movement led us now
berkeley has
more censorship of conservative views
than anywhere else in the country
practically
it is a trap it is a trick that we fell
for this is the exact trick that i
describe in my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available now for pre-order who
knows for how long but thank you to all
of all
of you who have pre-ordered already it
seems that a lot of people have done
that
bill buckley in in god and man at yale
calls academic freedom a hoax
it is a farce we do not first of all
it's not possible
to discuss all views in the classroom
and we wouldn't want to do that even if
we could
in the classroom we do not discuss
uh for instance how two plus two can
equal five
it some people might think that two plus
two equals five but it it doesn't that's
wrong we exclude that view
from the classroom in the classroom
we do not include the view that the the
holocaust didn't happen
just to use a popular example there are
actually quite a number of people who
hold that view but we don't teach that
because the historical evidence is that
the germans committed atrocities against
the jews and other people
in the second world war we do not
include the view
in the classroom that the moon is made
of green cheese
some people might hold that view but we
don't include it the truth
is exclusive and curricula
are exclusive when when you go to a
liberal arts college
you're probably not going to learn how
to be a mechanic
you would have you'd have to go to a
different college that's not what that
college is for colleges have missions
they are teaching towards something now
colleges seem to have lost their sense
of purpose
though they only really seem that way
the colleges were begun as seminaries
harvard and yale were seminaries they
are seminaries still they're just
seminaries of subjectivism of leftism
you have to exclude certain views and i
think we need to do that because i think
falling for the trap of the free speech
movement at berkeley
what did it get us it got us this the
same exact limitations on speech we
always had
it's only now the speech that was being
excluded was ordinary truthful
conservative speech and and the the only
views that were being included
were were liberal views
critical race theory must be excluded
from the classroom
because it and associated academic
movements deny
reason critical race theory and
associated
pseudo-academic movements reject
objective
truth for narrative they say it's all
just kind of words words words
so the people who develop this thing who
i describe in in my book speechless
describe it as a radically different
academic sort of movement
it's meant to foment a radical ideology
to upend our traditional culture
it is an example of what chesterton
would call the thought that stops
thought which of course is the only
thought that ought to be stopped
i hope i hope i've made my point even
though i greatly admire both of these
men
i think what what professor george and
what uh christopher ruffo are describing
is an opinion that is very very popular
among conservatives but i i just
i don't think it's the old-fashioned
traditional opinion and i think we've
we've got to be able to push
a little bit further i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]